qu'est ce que les gens pensent et
cherchent sur moi ouais je suis là d'un
doigt je commence mes vidéos sans être
devant la caméra
aujourd'hui cette chaise me patrick ou à
jamioulx a fait un truc j'ai jamais fait
mais qui a déjà été fait par tous les
gens de d'internet on va ce google et
ceux googleliser appelez ça comme vous
voulez on va voir ce que les gens
veulent savoir sur moi on va voir ce que
les gens disent sur moi on va flatter
mon ego comme jamais déjà atteint mais
qui pèse quand tu tapes la première
lettre de ton pseudo sur google sather
ton pseudo en premier ça soit yahoo
c'est mieux c'est grave le voilà légaux
et briser ces mots on peut avancer est
ce qu au bond les blagues sur les gosses
ont terminé il fallait les faire passer
par un squeeze squeeze youtube c'est
plutôt qu avec ce quiz is the last
guardian ça fait plaisir on est heureux
de voir que les gens ont entendu parler
du let's play ont voulu le trouver en
tapant secoue this last guardian sur
google squeeze quotidien ah oui vous
voulez dire vous l'âme elle avec
modestie
voilà désolé il est encore plein de
poussière c'est que mes trophées je m'en
fous je j'en tiens pas compte' squeeze
twitter va tu tapes squeeze dans twitter
ça plus vite aussi choisi âge très bonne
question quel âge un squeeze il a 21 ans
il est né le 27 janvier 96 le vrai âge
de squeeze c'est quoi ça et bien cette
mouvance vous pour une nouvelle vidéo
sur un an dépassant de vacances et avec
un premier pas oui oui j'ai déjà essayé
sauf qu'en fait c'était pour voir si ça
marchait pas à la mecque s'est fait
griller par son historique buts à un
petit j'ai une photo c'est celle là
alors quel âge quel âge est offert une
prédiction moi je pense on vrai il a 12
ans 23 ans
what the fuck mon dieu 42e [ __ ] de
merde
après les mecs plus vieux les filles
elles bien bon dialogue et 12 ans bon
alors squeeze salaires oui l'argent des
abonnés alors selon les échos squeeze
est en tête avec 480 milles or au hamas
et en un an cyprien engrange 360 ni les
nordmann ferme la marche avec comme il
l'indiquait cent mille euros touchés ce
qui est excellent c'est qu'il n'a jamais
indiqué serge lama fils de où il fait
bon jour à tout ce qui touche 100 mille
euros par an maintenant on va parler des
chats et ben non
et ben non il n'a jamais dit chez plus
c'est quoi l'histoire exacte mais c'est
dans une émission qui ont posé la
question il est un peu en mode malaise
comme quand tu demandes à n'importe
quelle personne au monde combien ils
gagnent sur un plateau télé devant 300
mille personnes
il avait il répond je sais plus trop
quoi et les médias ont fait aucun
gagnent 100 mille euros c'est pourquoi
il l'a dit et on sort 480000 euros
[ __ ]
le mec est pas foutu d'acheter une vraie
pipe [ __ ] bouygues votre facture
toujours impayées pour la règle rdv sur
votre espace client 480000 euros par an
et paye pas sa facture de téléphone le
court squeeze taille ou attention je
crois que sur ce site amatai un mètre 69
mahomet bien vous pouvez l'acheter le
soixante dix on passe à la disette du
dessus je gagne moins deux points de
virilité chez eux ils ont fait ça pour
me faire chier ils savent déjà que comme
truc qu'on dit que moi dans la rue c'est
bien évidemment m étais petit un vrai et
moi je suis un bonhomme sur 12 le mec je
peux pas le laisser me parler comme ça
du coup je dis quoi oui t'as vu je suis
vraiment petit et pas crédible en vrai
ce site a reconnu et flippant qui
regroupe bataille est tous là j'aime pas
du tout régularité quatre vidéos par
semaine
c'est vrai affiliation cyprin gaming et
razer c'est trop lent et comparera pote
a vraiment une marque qui vend des
claviers quoi c'est bien joué a mal pris
à ta place mais bon après son snack
chasse squeeze lucasson je savais même
pas que j'avais même pas je crois que je
vais m'installer snapshot à je tourne au
mais regardez qu'est ce qui vous a fait
glisser venez je tourne la caisse qui a
déjà affirmé qu'ils se passe pourquoi
j'aimerais chibret la presse intervient
dans toutes les attentes eu à regarder
pour ce premier jeu vidéo
non moi le rap c'est figuration je
marche it's never said peur pour sa vie
de ta vidéo sur saône est pas d'accord
je dois comprendre pourquoi les
gendarmes agissaient vd forcément jcvd
les joueurs karim achoui s'est joué
devant moi s'il te plaît bon dans l'air
et quoi les atomes les atomes sa ronde
par le nez les oreilles c'est pas pareil
c'est un canal c'est différent si tu
connecte les deux cas le mind et le
corps en santé parce que les molécules
devant bien sûr quand tu les as pire par
l'onu s'en sort par la bouche ses 10 ans
en parle plus et du vent c'est du péché
d'orgueil
à bientôt diane love you bon on peut
reprendre maintenant un squeeze hanouna
ah oui je me souviens de ça quand j'ai
peur des menaces étaient quant aux
chercheurs étudiants web et sur youtube
on a quoi pokémon go horreur squeeze
malaise malaise étant le mot le plus
détesté du monde à l'heure qu'il est
c'est quoi remplace-t-on le parent
gênante pour changer un peu
c'est encore pire squeeze baptiste aux
jeunes anecdotes incroyables vous
raconter je suis allé au mondial tous au
salon du mondial du tas du tatouage a
fait à paris bonjour que c'était à la
porte de la villette je crois ou
peut-être une connerie bref j'étais est
en balade en rien mais qui m'arrêtent et
qui me dit
un squeeze et je reconnais sa voix et je
fais chier tu es là il m'a sorti le truc
qui m'a fait le plus plaisir de ces dix
dernières années je suis le frère de
bâtisses tu me reconnais pas tuer du
monde tout court et ouais j'ai rencontré
le frère de baptiste wataru tard poterie
qui l'a rencontré johnny depp brad pitt
mes mecs là on parle du frère de
baptiste on parle d'une légende et le
bad c'est que je devais aller voir un
truc et en revenant à l'endroit où je
l'avais vu il était il était plus là
bravo moi je l'aurais vu ne serait-ce
qu'une éclat vite fait alors si on tape
squeeze et squeeze est un illuminé c'est
bon ça reste sur y avait un tatouage et
un triangle un endroit sentir moscou les
iq routes thierry vilain comme les boys
lumineux
coïncidence je ne pense pas allons voir
ces de plus près au nom le logo de
squeeze enlevons de cercle trafic ont
quelques tellement bien joué le
théoricien tu as vu le triangle dans mon
logo bien joué alors y'a quoi d'autre
sinon on est morts est morte squeeze
nous a quittés à l'âge de 17 ans en
effet le youtuber est mort en plein vol
lors de son voyage à madagascar
l'avion a rencontré une baleine volante
qui a violemment détourner l'appareil
bilan 322 survivants sauf squeeze et
tant mieux [ __ ] mais internet même
vous sentez vous hanter cette amo envers
moi moi je le sens et c'est ce qui me
donne invite quand et ne veut pas brûler
accent québécois mais [ __ ] [ __ ]
squeeze et riche
je savais pas que c'était possible des
tubes heures devenir millionnaire grâce
à ça moi non plus si près un squeeze et
norman touche des millions grâce à la
vidéo et se font tacler des clans réussi
en france on se fait descendre ya des
youtuber aucune n'avait pas ce qu'ils
ont mais squeeze cyprien et norman et
même d'autres font plus que juste faire
des vidéos
non non non non c'est gentil mais non il
fait juste des vidéos on peut pas je
fais rien d'autre et régulièrement
j'appuie sur le toit de cette voiture
voilà squeeze et gauche et wi harper
d'aller gaucher est peut-être le mec qui
gagnerait à écrire au stylo plume parce
que leurs mains et allait lancer pour
vous ce quiz et en attendant b un
squeeze grosso fob sexiste what else
espaces et leron flex voilà comment en
début d'une vidéo sur pokémon go squeeze
youtuber bien connu et très suivi par
d'une femme visiblement en surpoids
qu'il croise dans la rue lors de son
tournage ya un nombre incalculable
d'articles comme ça sur le web sur moi
et sur d'autres
et [ __ ] mais des fois mais péter un
[ __ ] de coûts arrêté deux des
fondateurs prix tout en un mot n'a pas
de raison qu'on n'y a rien à défendre en
fait c'est juste du second degré de
l'humour c'est tellement original
n'est-ce pas de comparer une personne
gros c'est un animal réel ou imaginaire
c'est tellement originale de faire un
article en disant que quelqu'un est
sexiste et grossier alors c'est une
[ __ ] de vidéos humoristiques des
vidéos part en couille bon clairement en
tapant mon nom va surtout tombée sur des
articles comme ça ça veut dire que dans
les vidéos tu dois te retenir tout le
temps de faire des blagues des trucs
parce que c'est pas politiquement
correct franchement je pense que vous me
connaissez vous savez que jamais géré
offensé des gens harceler des gens faire
chier gratuitement des gens bien au
contraire je me bats tous les jours
contre ça je trouve ça un peu triste que
des gens soient autant sur la défensive
tout le temps et qu'ils aient autant
besoin de combattre les choses tout le
temps y compris des choses qui des fois
non pas besoin d'être combattue genre là
c'est juste une 20 dans une vidéo
humoristique c'est stop y est t'as pas
un combat à mener parce que j'ai dit que
la meuf était en flex pour la blague
mois on traite de squelettes et puis ces
lots est ce que j'en fait tout un plat
bombay coup ya au moins c'est du second
degré elle s'est tarie gaulle est un
bâtard [ __ ] c'est nul maintenant là il
ya que des articles sur les thunes et le
elle fait que ce soit un gros sexiste
raciste fils de [ __ ] mais ça on le sait
tous déjà on n'apprend rien [ __ ] bon
finish sur squeeze à moi je sais pas
vous mais quand même quand on est passés
squeeze la manche et à se mouiller et
sexiste être que non tu es moche c'est
forcément sexiste du coucher pas à
squeeze fait on l'a pas fait cela
squeeze fait des vidéos là tu t'es
trompé youtuber la juste trouver d'où tu
viens
norman tu pèses tellement que correct
fait des vidéos les gens tapent
forcément nanas fêlées vidéos quizz il
fait la cuisine
là vous vous êtes clairement trompé de
personne squeeze fait peur c'est de pire
en pire c'est pour tomber sur les vidéos
du jeu d'horreur ou genre c'est vraiment
un mec qui a peur de moi et qui cherche
des gens qui sont dans la même situation
que lui pour témoigner a tant qui
apparaît en premier quand on tape
youtube
c'est mon ego ces mondiaux il commença à
eybens et déjà la fin de cette vidéo
pourquoi j'en air sérieux on sait pas
n'hésitez pas à aller mais ça vous a plu
puis ne cherchez pas votre nom sur
google pourquoi soit ça va flatter votre
ego vous finir avec votre visite dans
votre propre bouche sans même vous en
rendre compte soit ça va le briser en
mille mais c'est l'un ou l'autre c'est
blanc ou noir comme dans la tête des
gens qui font des articles pour dénoncer
du sexisme et du racisme là où il y en a
pas ou il était subtil et bien merci à
vous regarder la vidéo on se quitte sous
cette mine de critérium qui tombe comme
souvent quand tu étais au collège et là
je galère à la remettre
comme souvent quand tu étais au collège
aussi que vous êtes encore là
[Musique]
ça